hi there steve kaufman here again to
talk about language learning as usual
and today i want to talk about what
makes a language easy to learn remember
um if you like my videos please
subscribe if you like this video please
give it a like
i'm often asked you know how long does
it take to learn a language which
languages is easiest to learn are some
languages easier than others and so
forth so here's my take on what makes
languages easier
the first thing is how much similar
vocabulary is there okay if you are an
english speaker learning french 50 of
the vocabulary or more is recognizable
so therefore easy to learn
and and i'll explain why that gives you
big advantages um
if you are uh you know even um
i don't know even if you're learning
german there's gonna be i don't know
what the percentage is but there's a lot
of words there that you recognize
and where that's not the case for
example right now i'm struggling with
arabic persian and
turkish they're essentially there are
very few it's a ten percent
uh words that are recognizable from a
european language uh there's another
number of words that i recognize
because they connect arabic and persian
and turkish so they're common to those
three languages and so to that extent
that helps so to me the overwhelming
consideration is the amount of
recognizable vocabulary when i after
learning russian czech has about 60
percent of
vocabulary that is recognizable from
russian
uh that gives you a big head start
um and and the reason that's important
is because the second thing that
influences how difficult or easy a
language is to learn is the available
the availability of interesting
compelling content in that language and
that means that you have to be able to
get from sort of beginner
material material sort of designed for
the learner to material that's genuinely
interesting so i'm trying to and i did
for arabic and for persian try to get to
podcasts and and movies and things that
are genuinely interesting but it's very
difficult because
the gap between the beginner the
beginner materials such as our many
stories where there's a lot of
repetition of vocabulary to get from
that to sort of genuinely interesting
material is a much bigger gap because
there are so few words that you
recognize whereas if you are in french
or spanish or
even having done one slavic language you
go to another slavic language you can
much more quickly
get to a situation as i was in those
languages say in even in polish or in
ukrainian where you can find genuine
genuinely interesting stuff podcasts
whatever that you can listen to take
with you every day and so you're you're
no longer consciously learning the
language you are learning about
interesting things
using the language and your language
skills are developing so to me
that's the big thing how close are the
languages in terms of vocabulary and
therefore how quickly can you get on to
interesting content the other
consideration of course is the
availability of interesting content but
that's increasingly there it's sometimes
difficult to find you can look for it in
the itunes library or on netflix or
you know radio stations online or
anywhere where they have material that
you can
access
uh i for example now i'm looking for
turkish podcasts and i'm gonna put the
podcast or maybe
yeah put the podcast on to uh this happy
scribe or happy transcribe it is this
transcription service
or with our link extension i can take uh
you know youtube videos that have
subtitles
and automatically import them into link
as study material
um you know korean a big obstacle for me
while korean shares a lot of vocabulary
with chinese and japanese to the extent
that they share chinese origin
vocabulary
these are hidden for me in korean
because i don't know what the characters
are
now in link for example in japanese we
have the you can show
on the lesson page you can show the the
furigana in other words the hiragana
sort of phonetic
script for what you are reading or you
can show the romaji so we have the
ability to show another line of text it
would be amazing if in my korean
learning we could get a hold of some
automatic conversion of korean into
kanji into chinese characters where
those characters exist and then to show
that
uh you know on top of the text which is
all in hangul so these would be all
sorts of ways of making genuinely
interesting material more accessible
otherwise it's a big struggle to get
from sort of easy material to genuinely
compelling material especially when
all of the words have to be learned
whereas not all because some of the
words are forms of other words but
you don't have so much common vocabulary
that helps you get sort of to transition
from beginner material to genuinely
compelling material so just my take on
what makes a language difficult it's not
word order it's not even the grammar
to me it's words how
many sort of how many words are
recognizable based on languages that you
know
and that is going to help you transition
to more interesting content which will
then speed you on your way
to learning the language i look forward
to your
comments thank you bye
you